-Thank you very much
to all of you five people.
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
It is Friday, everybody.
That's a great reaction.
That is -- you don't
understand.
That is a great reaction.
There's only five people here.
Let's get to the news
and jokes.
Well, guys, last night was
the start of the NFL season.
And I got to say, it was kind of
strange to see
a live sport event with
fans in the crowd.
I was a little worried at first
until I saw the crowd
at the president's rally
in Michigan last night.
Yikes!
I need a nasal swab just
from looking at that.
[ Laughter ]
If you're trying to figure out
how many Bob Woodward tapes
we need for people to take
COVID seriously,
it appears the answer is
more than 18.
What are they doing?
Even the cardboard cutouts at
Major League Baseball games
are more spread out than that.
Can we see that photo again?
Wow!
That's a lot of white people.
Looks like a mosh pit
at a Kenny G concert.
[ Laughter ]
People --
Dude, once he goes into
"Songbird," it's like --
Wah!
[ Vocalizing smooth jazz ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
People are calling last night's
rally --
-Can we do that?
-We should.
-Mosh to Kenny G?
-I would totally mosh
to Kenny G.
Last time I tried moshing,
I went to, like,
I wanna say, one of the later
Lollapaloozas.
And I was like,
"I can handle myself.
I can mosh.
[ Light laughter ]
It's cool. I could --
it's totally cool.
Let's get in there."
And, dude, I got a boot to the
head, and I was like,
too old, too old.
-I wore Birkenstocks to see
Henry Rollins.
-No, that was the end of that.
-Never again.
-You lost three toes.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It was like, old guy, old guy
in the mosh pit!
Old guy! Just get the old guy
out. They carried me out.
That's right, people are
calling last night's rally
a super spreader event.
When he heard that,
Trump was like,
"Amazing, even CNN
said it was super."
And everyone's talking about
this moment from the rally.
Did you see this yet?
Oh, my goodness.
So Trump is trying to go through
the history of Michigan,
but he stumbled over the word
Motown.
Check it out.
-Michigan gave us Motang.
Gave us Motown.
Give us the Mustang.
[ Laughter ]
-Mo...
-Motan.
-"All the Motang's
great artists,
like Smokey Robinsang,
Marvin Gang,
and the Jacksgang Five.
Who could forget the great
Motown song,
"Papa Was a Roping Stone?"
[ Laughter ]
I'm just going to do a million
of these, man.
Trump was like,
"I even love all the rappers
in the Motang Clan."
[ Laughter ]
"That's right. Michigan gave us
Heidi Motang,
Spencer, LC, and of course,
Brody Jenner."
[ Laughter ]
Later on, Trump said,
"Motang, of course, began
in the great city of De-twa."
[ Laughter ]
Right after that,
"Yo-semite" National Park
was like, "Damn, you too?"
Yeah, Trump mispronounced
Motown as Motang.
It was a simple mistake,
but to prove that he's actually
a huge fan of Motown,
he released this message.
Take a look.
-I'm Donald J. Trump,
here to talk about
all the fantastic artists
that came out of Motown.
Artists like Betty White,
the Burrito Supremes,
Orville Redenbacher,
Marvin
Word Mike Pence Won't Say,
Stevie Wonder, Ray Charles,
Glade Plug-ins,
and my personal favorite,
Eats Domino's.
[ Laughter ]
-Later in the rally,
Trump mentioned an award
that he's won in the past that
I didn't really know about.
Watch this.
-Well, I was honored
in Michigan.
Does anybody know that?
I was given Man of the Year
award by somebody.
[ Laughter ]
If you --
[ Laughs ]
-If you don't remember
the Michigan Man of the Year
Awards, there's a reason.
They don't exist.
His staff was like,
"When he's in a bad mood,
we just give him a trophy with
a post-it note on it.
Just take it."
Trump's just making up awards.
"I was named Michigan's
Man of the Year,
Wisconsin's
Most Stable Genius,
and Ohio's Sexiest Man Alive."
Trump said he was given
the award by somebody.
Honestly, the only thing
foggier than that claim
is Andy Reid's
face shield.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of awards, the Trump
campaign tried to celebrate
the president's Nobel Prize
nomination on Facebook,
but they had some trouble
with the spelling.
This is real.
Look at what they posted.
They spelled Nobel wrong.
-No.
-That is real.
-They spelled Nobel --
Trump saw that and was like,
"You idiots.
It's prize with an "s."
[ Laughter ]
And get this, during
a White House press conference
yesterday,
Trump started talking about
the TV shows that he watches.
It was a pretty long list.
Listen to this.
-I watch some of the shows.
I watch Liz McDonald.
She's fantastic.
I watched Fox Business.
I watched Lou Dobbs
last night,
Sean Hannity last night,
Tucker last night, Laura.
I watched "Fox & Friends"
in the morning.
[ Snores ]
-That's seven hours of TV
he's listed.
It would have been quicker
to just name the shows
on Fox News
he doesn't watch.
"Everything but Chris Wallace."
Yeah, at the end of every night,
Trump's TV turns to
his phone and goes,
[panting] "Okay, your turn."
[ Laughter ]
Check this out.
I saw that Starbucks
just made a pretty big
announcement.
Listen to this.
-Starbucks is getting rid
of straws
on most of its iced drinks.
The coffee giant is rolling out
so-called sippy cup lids
for the beverages.
-Here's an idea.
If you want this to catch on,
maybe don't call them
sippy cups.
"We got a little baby
sippy cup for Jeff?"
Sippy cup for Jeff?"
Meanwhile, over at Dunkin
Donuts, they'll give you a straw
that comes packaged inside
two other straws.
But don't worry, the plastic
straws aren't going to waste.
Starbucks said that
they'll be melted down
and turned into breakfast
sandwiches.
[ Laughter ]
Here's something kind of
surprising.
I heard that Oscar Mayer is
offering up its iconic
Wienermobile for people's
marriage proposals.
Here's the actual
promotional photo.
Yep.
Oscar Mayer says they'll
keep loaning it out
until one of the proposals
ends with a yes.
[ Laughter ]
I'm into this.
It's a great way to show
your future wife
that she should be the one
who handles the money.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the St. Louis Zoo
says a python
just laid seven eggs,
but check out
why it's making headlines.
-This 50-year-old python
shocked zookeepers
by laying eggs.
It was surprising because she
hasn't been near a male snake
in 15 years.
-When the news broke,
the iguana in the next exhibit
was like, "Look, it was late,
we were drunk.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not proud of it."
Meanwhile, one zookeeper
was like,
"Please don't look at the
security footage,
please don't look at
the security footage."
-Ew!
-"Please don't look."
[ Laughter ]